انا سعيده ان انا هنا معكم في دمياط واحب
اشارك معكم تجربتي
بس الاول عايزه اقول لكم ان ما فيش حاجه
بتبقى صدفه كل حاجه بتبقى مترتبه
وبيبقى في حكمه من كل حاجه المهم انت رد
فعلك هيبقى ايه في موقف ممكن الواحد يتعرض
له ما يعملش اي رد فعل ويبقى سلبي ويبقى
وجود الشخص ده زي عدمه وفي موقف تاني ممكن
بناء على رد فعلك انت او انت تغير حياه
بني ادم او بني ادمين واسر كتيره حياتها
تتغير وحياتك انت نفسها تتغير زي ما حياتي
انا اتغيرت
مره كنت بوزع بطاطين في عزبه خير الله دي
في القاهره احد العشوائيات هناك
وكان في زحمه كتير حوالين التوزيع فعلشان
الموضوع يقوم بسلاسه قمت اخدت الولاد
الصغيرين اللي موجودين على جنب وقعدت العب
معهم نمله ونخله وشمس وقمر ونجوم الليل
في وسط دوت واحده من الستات جت قالت لي
انت عيله انت عشان تلعبي مع العيال مش بدل
ما تساعدينا قاعده تلعبي مع العيال المهم
بعد ما التوزيع خلص ولما جيت امشي الولاد
من كتر ما انبسطوا ومش عارفين يعبروا
ومتضايقين ان الموضوع ده خلاص خلص خرجوا
عن السيطره وابتدوا يرموني بالزلط وبالتوب
ساعتها حسيت ان اي حاجه هتتعمل هتعمل فرق
بس السؤال ايه هو كانت الحاجه اللي بتتعمل
عزبه خير الله منطقه عشوائيه الناس راحوا
وضعوا يد عليها فبنوا حاجات غير رسميه
بطريقه مش منظمه خالص الاسر هناك الاسره
بتبقى مكونه من خمس ست سبع اشخاص قاعده في
اوضه واحده ما فيش ساعتها لكن ميه ولا صرف
ما فيش تهويه نسبه الامراض عاليه
نسبه مشاكل كثيره هتبقى موجوده وفي نفس
الوقت برضو في ما فيش مجاري في حاجه اسمها
ترانشات الابيار فبما ان ما فيش مفهوم
النظافه فعادي العيال قاعدين على
الترانشات وماشيين حافيين على ميه المجاري
ما فيش حد خالص بيقول لهم اي حاجه
كان ساعتها باين
ان الحل مش في البطانيه ولا في كرتونه
رمضان
بس هي هي الحاجه اللي فعلا هتطلع طلعهم من
خط الفقر ايه الحاجه اللي هتخليهم يستغنوا
عن العوز وعن المسكنات الخيريه
قلنا طيب نجرب نعمل محو اميه للسيدات
فجبنا 200 سيده وجمعيه ووضبناها وساعدناهم
بحيث ان احنا ابتدينا اول نشاط نعمله هناك
بس لقينا انك تغير عقليه ست كبيره مشغوله
بعيالها واولادها وجوزها اللي في البيت
واللي ما بيشتغلش والامراض اللي موجوده مش
سهله خالص انها تبقى تستقبل اي معلومات او
اي حاجه عن التربيه الايجابيه او محو
الاميه
هنا طيب بلاش الامهات نشوف الشباب في شباب
كتير موجودين في المنطقه
بس اكتشفنا ان كلهم غير متعلمين فعمرنا ما
هنعرف نلاقي لهم وظيفه هيفضلوا يا اما
سواق توك توك او نجار مسلح او كده
فقعدنا نفكر لحد ما كان بديه يساعدها
بالنسبه لنا ان هو ايه تفتكروا الحل
الصغيرين برافو وعملنا قلنا الصغيرين
نبتدي معهم كتعاليم
وفعلا زي ما بيتقال المثل النقشه على
الحجر
من صغر زي النقشه على ايه على الحجر
وابتدينا اجراءات انشاء جمعيا سنه 2008 مع
مجموعه من الاصدقاء والعيله
جزء جوزي معي دلوقتي من ضمن العيله
واشتريناه بيت قديم ورممناه علشان يبقى
مدرسه تحت وزاره التربيه والتعليم للاطفال
المتسربين من التعليم
[تصفيق]
وده كان اول طوبه نحطها في ان احنا هنبتدي
الحلم بتاعنا ان الولاد
يعيش طفولتهم يحسوا باذنيتهم
وعملنا المدرسه للاطفال المتسربين من
التعليم واليوم دراسي كامل من الصبح لغايه
اخر النهار
بس يا ترى ايه كان اللي هيخلي الام تجيبه
ولادها عندنا ما تخليهوش يشتغل بره في
الورش الكتيره قوي اللي موجوده عشان ينجب
لها فلوس
فدينا قسم اسمه الانشطه الحرفيه
وابتدينا نعمل انشطه حرفيه بتطير داخل
للاسره او
للعيله بحيث ان يبقى الحافز ان الاهالي
يجيبوا ولاد عندهم غير طبعا ان احنا كنا
بنوفر اكل وبنوفر حاجات كتيره جدا بس كان
المهم بالنسبه لها ان يبقى في مردود ان هي
تجيبه عندنا لان هم ظروفهم ما نقدرش
نتجاهلها
والانشطه الحرفيه ديت اتزينها شويه شويه
في منسج تطريز كروشيه نحاس نجاره خياطه
وفي نفس الوقت برضو الاهالي كانوا
بيشتغلوا معهم فكان مصدر رزق برده له
وابتدي الولاد تثقيش حياه شويه طبيعيه
بس برضو كنا دايما بنحارب ان الناس الولاد
بيمشوا من عندنا فقعدنا نفكر ايه هي
الحاجه اللي هتخلي الولاد يبقوا متمسكين
بالمدرسه وعندهم انتماء وما يتسربوش تاني
فبجنب الانشطه الحرفيه اللي عندنا عملنا
انشطه فنيه وزي اي جمعيات وعملنا مسرحيه
وبنعمل عرض مسرح تمثيل وبعدين عرض طبله
عرض قرار وبعد فتره هنا ان احنا لازم
نتميز فبقينا ندبك العروض كلها مع بعض
وزودنا في الكلور اكروبات
موسيقى من تشيلو كمنجه
وبقينا نعمل عروض كامله متكامله فيها كل
حاجه المزيكا بتتلعب لايف الاولاد بيغنوا
الولاد بيعملوا اكروبات بيرقصوا فلكلور
ودائما ما بننساش ابدا الهويه المصريه
بحيث لما تتفرج على العرض تعرف ان ده عرض
معمول في مصر
فده مثلا عملنا عرضين مهمين قوي بالنسبه
لي عرض رمضان بتاع زمان اشتغلنا على
الفوازير واغاني المسلسلات دي مثلا الف
ليله وليله
وازاي الهويه المصريه بتبقى موجوده والعرض
التاني اسمه حتحور في الجبهخانه بيتكلم عن
حضارات مصر المختلفه والاديان اللي مرت
على مصر
لما بيطلعوا الاولاد على المسرح تسقيف
الجمهوري وتشجيعهم هو ده لو تشوفوا الضحكه
اللي على الولاد وعلى وشوشهم هو ده اللي
بيخليهم عايزين يكملوا وبيدي لهم امل
وبيحسوا بالميزه اللي هم فيها ان هم عندهم
حاجه مش موجوده عند ولاد كتيره في سنهم
وبتخلي برضو بقيه الولاد يخشوا ويندموا ان
في العزبه يبقوا عايزين ينضموا للمدرسه
وفي كل عرض بنعمله ببقى دايما حريصه ان
الجهه اللي بنعمل عندها عرضه لنا فلوس
بحيث اقدر اوزعها على الولاد فيحسوا
بالمردود المجهود اللي بيعملوه
السنه اللي فاتت وزاره التضامن الاجتماعي
عملت معنا شراكه ورحنا معهم محافظات بني
سويف والمنيا وسوهاج واسيوط تحت برنامج
حياه كريمه وحمله بالوعي مصر بتتغير
للاحسن
وهم مثلوا الظروف كان معنا العاملات اللي
في الجمعيه مشكله الزواج المبكر الكيف
الكثير الخلفه اللي وراء بعضيها مشاكل
الادمان والمخدرات وان في صندوق جمعيه
الوزاره بتقدمه بالعلاج فيه بالمجان
والبرامج الاقتصاديه للوزاره بتقدمها
وكانت الطلبه هم اللي كانوا بيمثلوا على
مدار 45 يوم كل يوم كانوا بيعرضوا وكل يوم
كانوا بياخدوا في الاعاليم عائد فلما
رجعنا بقى بعد الرحله كان اول مره الولاد
والستات يمسكوا مبلغ كبير في ايديهم
ده بالنسبه للانشطه الحرفيه الفنيه
بالنسبه للانشطه الحرفيه بما ان احنا
ابتدينا بالاول بزيرو خبره
المنتجات كانت بسيطه جدا وعلى قدها جدا
فبالتالي بيبيع كانوا قليل
بما ان السيدات والولاد بيتحاسبوا
بالانتاج فبالتالي كان بيحصل خلافات كتيره
ما بينهم علشان كان المردود لهم قليل فكل
واحده عايزه تكوش على الفصول اللي بتاخدها
البلاد اللي بره اللي عندهم حضارات ازاي
يستخدموا الحضارات بتاعتهم ووظفوها في
المنتجات بتاعتهم وهو ده بيبقى سفير كل
دوله لما تشوف المنتج ده تعرف ده موجود
معمول في الهند او في الصين او في اي حته
فبالتالي يبقى دورنا ان احنا نمصر
المنتجات ونعمل منتجات المصريه
بترمز لبلدنا وبثقافتنا وبتراسنا اللي هو
غني جدا
فده هنبتدي باول مثال دي الجلابيه عاديه
في نعمه من الانترنت ومن اخدنا الحتت
السودا ديت وده استخدام لبس كل عصى بس
الفرق ان احنا حطينا القماش بدل ما هو
اسود
اسلامي دهبي ما بيبهدش ما بينطحش
واسلام اسلامي زخارف اسلاميه
والجلابيه برضو لان دي من الحاجات المهمه
اللي بتتلبس كثير ده كف
ده فلكلور شعبي تراثي وده تطريز يدوي بحيث
ان يبقى دايما بيستخدم وفيه عماله كثيره
شغاله فبالتالي في مردود بيرجع للناس وهي
بتشتغل
ده اول حاجه كانت مستوحين استوحينا منها
فكره الشنط الشنط ده اهم خط انتاجي عندنا
لان انت الشنطه تبقى بمبلغ والعيال وكل
يوم ناس تبقى عايزه تمسك شنطه مختلفه بس
حاولنا ان احنا ازاي نمصر الفكره دي مخده
هندي هما استخدموا الموتيفات بتاعه الهند
وقرروها بحيس تبقى طريقه معاصره دي مخده
مكسيكي فخدنا اعتمدنا على المثلثات
الموجوده والهلالات واخدنا برضو من النوبه
الثقافه بتاعتها
وحطيناها في المخده وده تطريز المنسك وده
المنتج النهائي للمخده غير الهندي في
المصري برضو استخدمناه في حاجات تانيه ان
احنا قعدنا توظيفه ده مفرش صوان خياليه
كان بيستخدم زمان في الافراح
واخدنا الورده اللوتس ديت وشفنا موديل
شنطه موجود بره وقومنا عملنا الشنطه
اسلامي لوتس يدوي بخرز عصريه تقدر تستخدم
في ظروف كثيره نفس الحكايه موديل شنطه
تاني خدنا نفس الورده اللوتس وعملناها
بحرفه الخيامات
عارفين ده اسمه ايه
ده اسمه سوزاني ده في بلد جايه من اسمها
وده مشهور جدا بره له قيمه عاليه لان كل
ده تطريز يدوي ففي نفس الوقت اخدنا بدل
الدواير اللي موجوده عملناها بالكفوف اللي
احنا عاملينها وتطريز يدوي والبرواز
الاسلامي بحيث ان احنا دايما بنشوف بره
ايه وازاي نقدر نمسرها ويبان فعلا ده منتج
مصري ده وجهه جامع في الضرب الاحمر اسمه
الجامع الازرق فاخدنا المقارنوسات ديت
وعملناها في شنطه تطريز برضو
غير كل الحاجات المنسوكات كان فيه قلنا
نعمل حاجات شغل نحاس يدوي فجبنا راجل من
لسان الخليج بيعمل اطباق توت عنخ امون
ويفرتيتي زي اللي موجوده في الصين بالضبط
بتيجي مطبوعه ففهمنا التكنيكس بتاعته
والحرفيه بتاعته وبقينا نعمل ده فرع زينه
بيستخدم في رمضان بالدراويش حاجه من
التراث الاسلامي بتاعنا
طبعا اهم حاجه عندنا الحضاره اللي هي
المصريين القدماء وده عين حورس
وازاي لما استخدمناه في الخرز والفروز
والاحجار الكريمه نص كريمه بحيث حاجه لما
تشوفها تعرف النتيجه من مصر وتبقى بتمثل
مصر وتبقى فخور وانت شايلها عشان فيها
مصنعيه وحرفيه
هند رستم خير من مسيره التله في افلامها
بس التالي ده حاجه من زمان وموجوده في
سوهاج وما بقتش خلاص منتشره احنا بالصدفه
لقينا في عزبه خير الله وايمان كانت لسه
جايه من كذا سنه مع باباها نقلت من الصعيد
جت عزبه خير الله في القاهره اعملها فرصه
عمل احسن وكانت فاتحه كشك بتبيع فيه بقاله
فحاولنا نستغل قدراتها
وامكانياتها فانها تعلم الولاد والامهات
عندنا في الجمعيه
واخدناه بدل ما يبقى شفاف حطينا عليه
قماشه بحيث يقدر يستخدم
وقليل ما يبقاش كثير فيبقى فيه مش مكلفه
فاحنا اخدنا الصلوات اللي موجوده في عزبه
خير الله وحاولنا نستخدمها عارفين ايه
الحرفه المشهوره قوي الوحيده اللي بتتعمل
هنا في دمياط ما فيش حد في مصر تاني
بيعملها غير الاساس طبعا
ها
الايه
غير المشبك
هو برضو ما فيش حد بيعمل غير في دمياط
الاولى منديل
اللي هو دوت وهو ده مش موجود في حته غير
هنا اهو واللي بيشتغل الاوقاف في دمياط
يتعدوا على الصوابع وكبار في السن
ولازم تحاولوا تشوفوا ازاي تستغلوا الثروه
اللي موجوده بس في دمياط وتحاولوا توظفوها
بطريقه ان تبقى يكسر انتشارها
اللي احنا توصلنا له ده ما جاش في يوم
وليله احنا قعدنا كتير عقبال ما عرفنا
نعمل كدهوت وتجربنا كثير وفشلنا كثير مش
عيب ان احنا نغلط المهم نتعلم من اخطائنا
وفهمنا ان لازم يبقى في هويه مصريه لازم
ان احنا ما نزهقش لازم نجرب لازم نشوف رد
فعل الناس اللي بتشتري فعلا متضايقه وايه
رد فعلها
الستات نفسهم لما شافوا شغلهم القديم اللي
بيعملوه بيقولوا اصحيه احنا كنا بنعمل شغل
وحش كده هم نفسهم ذوقهم اتحسن
الاولاد لما كبروا الحلم كبر معه فاشترينا
ارض 2000 سنه 2013 في عزبه خيران لالف متر
عشان نعمل مدرسه تستوعب الحلم اللي قاعد
بيكبر جوانا
وكان عندي طلب بسيط جدا ان انا عايزه ارخص
ارض في منطقه عشوائيه غير رسميا مش متخصصه
ان انا ارفص الارض وان انا اعمل رخصه
مباني
وده حاجه ما حصلتش قبل كده هوت فلكوا ان
تتخيلوا ان انا كنت ان انا بنت عيله بشعري
دوت بخش في مكاتب الدوله والحكومه وبطلب
حاجه وهم مش فاهمين فكانوا شايفين كائن
فضائي
بس كان عندي اصرار وعندي حلم ماشيه وراه
ان انا شايفه ان ولاد عزبه خيرالله
والامهات تستاهلوا عيشه احسن من كده ومن
غير الحلم ده والاصرار ما كانش فيه حاجه
هتحصل
وكان دايما بيقابل بالرفض
بس كنت بقول
هيحصل وكنت عندي اصرار وعزيمه
وكنت اقول لهم انا مش عايزه اعمل مدرسه في
حته متقسمه زي الزمالك انا عايزه اعمل
مدرسه في حته الاكثر احتياجا اللي ما
فيهاش مدارس
وعشان ربنا دايما معنا فبعد التلات سنين
قدرنا كنت دايما في كل مكتب تكوني سواء
وزاره حي محافظه وزاره شركه المعادي
لابنيه التعليميه بلاقي حد ربنا حط في
طريقي علشان يساعدنا ازاي نحاول نحل
المشكله رسمي وقانوني وازاي نقدر نرخص
الارض بعد مشوار كفاح تلات سنين قدرنا
فعلا نلخص الارض سنه 2016 وابتدينا نحط
حجر الاساس للمدرسه
فديسمبر عشرين عشرين فتحنا المدرسه
وابتدينا فهمنا ساعتها كنا بالظبط عايزين
ايه عملنا الفصول وعملنا المكتبه معمل
الكمبيوتر اهم مساحه موجوده هو الملعب ان
مساحه امنه الولاد كانوا يلعبوا فيها
المطعم حته بيفطروا ويتغدوا فيها مكان
الحرف السيدات والاطفال بيتعلموا في الحرف
وبياخدوا عائد مادي سيرك مساحه الارض
ارتفاع خمسه متر السقف بحيث يقدروا
يتمرنوا كويس ويقدروا بدل ما احنا كنا قبل
كده بنتمرن في وسط واحنا ناس ماجرين
ودايما بيتخانقوا معنا عشان عاملين لهم
ازعاج
مسرح الولاد بيعرضوا فيه واهاليهم يقدروا
يشوفوهم لان قبل كده ما كانش في مكان
الولاد ممكن اهاليهم يشوفوهم فابشافوا
فعلا قد ايه ولادهم كبروا في عنيهم لما
شافوا القدرات المميزه اللي بيعملوها
دلوقتي الحلم ان احنا نبني جمعيه تواصل
ومدرسه تواصل في كل حته في كل محافظه في
مصر
اللي انا عايزه اقوله
ان ما فيش حاجه بتبقى صدفه كل شيء بيبقى
مترتب انا لما رحت اوزع بطاطين استغليت
الفرصه شفت حاجه حاولت ان انا ابقى لي رد
الفعل وده ما كانش هيحصل غير لو انا دايما
بحاول وبنزل الشارع وبجرب اه ولا واعافر
وراسي
جزمه
عشان في حاجه عايزه احققها فهو لازم يبقى
عندكم حلم لازم تبقوا ورا الموضوع
انا الحمد لله جايه من اسره كويسه وظروفنا
الحمد لله كويسه واسره جميله وكنت بشوف ان
دوري ان انا ارد جنيز واحاول اعمل فرق في
حياه الناس الاقل حظا لان انا كان ممكن
ابقى في مكانهم كل مجهود بتعمله بيعمل فرق
حتى ولو صغير كل مجهود بيعمل فرق كل مجهود
له مردود انتم نفسكم لما بتعملوا مجهود
بيبقى عندكم ثقه بالنفس واحساس بالرضا ما
لوش مثيل المهم تشوفه ايه الاثر اللي
هتسيبوه في الدنيا شكرا
[تصفيق]